lassen Sie mich
vorab den Zweige töteten Handwerkern in
Ludwigshafen gedenken die vor zwei Tagen
von einem Somalia ermordet wurden Frau
Hasselmann das schmerzt ich wünsche den
Familien und Hinterbliebenen viel Kraft
ich wünsche den verletzten schnelle
Genesung
und auch das ist mittlerweile Normalität
in Deutschland kommen wir zum
Europäischen Rat der heute und morgen in
Brüssel zusammentritt um den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und seine
Auswirkungen auf die Energiekrise und
die Wirtschaften Europa behandelt so
auch der Titel einerseits scheint die
Brisanz einer Energiekrise in den Köpfen
angekommen zu sein andererseits
verwechselt man hier wieder Ursache und
Wirkung eine Antwort auf die Krise soll
jedenfalls der sogenannte
gaspreisdeckel sein so hören wir es und
so lesen wir es jedoch bleiben hier mehr
Fragen offen kann die Energie-
wie wird der Verteilschlüssel sein nach
Bedarf wie viel mehr kostet dem
Steuerzahler die gemeinsame Beschaffung
im Vergleich zur nationalen Beschaffung
dazu gab es heute vom Bundeskanzler
keine Antworten gemeinsam mit den
europäischen Staaten die
Energieversorgung sicherzustellen kann
ein Weg sein wenn Deutschland nicht mehr
investieren muss und mit allen
europäischen Partnern im guten Kontakt
und nicht teilweise im Krieg stehen
würde der Kontinent Europa verfügt über
ausreichend Energiereserven um sich zu
versorgen deshalb wäre zusätzliches
teures und schmutziges Fracking Gas
einzukaufen überhaupt nicht notwendig
dafür braucht es aber eine Infrastruktur
die durch die Gemeinschaft auch
gesichert wird und in diesem
Zusammenhang frage ich Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler wo sie die
Untersuchungsergebnisse zur Sabotage an
Nordstemmen 1 und 2 wo die Ergebnisse
sind die habe ich schon vor einer Woche
gefragt sie haben noch in der letzten
Woche gesagt dass diese bald vorliegen
werden nun weigert sich Schweden uns
untersuchungsdetails zu nennen und da
frage ich sie entspricht das einem
vertrauensvollen Umgang innerhalb der
Europäischen Gemeinschaft gehen so
Freunde mit uns um
wir hatten und wir haben mit den
nordstream Pipelines die Möglichkeit als
Deutschland zu berälen und preiswert
unsere Energieversorgung sicherzustellen
und ebenso könnten darüber Teile Europas
auch bedient werden wir haben immer
dafür geworben dass ich die deutsche
Bundesregierung Option offen halten muss
Optionen um selbst handlungsfähig zu
bleiben damit der Wohlstand der
Wirtschaft der Industrie und damit der
Bevölkerung gesichert wird
alles das setzen sie mit ihren selbst
entfachten Wirtschaftskrieg der sich
hauptsächlich gegen uns gegen unsere
Bevölkerung richtet auf Spiel ihre
Maßnahmen und Hilfsprogramme kommen spät
und sind immer wieder schlechte
Kompromisse die in erster Linie den
Bürger langfristig nur Kosten
verursachen denn auch die 200 Milliarden
neues Sondervermögen
Schulden die am Ende der Steuerzahler
sowieso bezahlen muss das ist das
übliche Spiel linke Tasche rechte Tasche
und sie sind oben drei zum Teil
verfassungswidrig wie ist der
Bundesrechnungshof bereits schon
angekündigt hat und ich habe schon oft
gesagt sie hantieren ungeschickt und
drang an den Symptomen herum anstelle
sich den Ursachen endlich zu widmen und
diese liegen aktuell in ihrer Politik
der Sanktion daran scheinen sie wirklich
mittlerweile gefallen zu entwickeln
schauen Sie mal durch die wertebrille
Frau bärbung welches ist das nächste
Land von dem sich distanzieren wollen
sie gehen ja da schon eifrig voran es
ist schon wirklich eigenartig das gerade
aus der Partei die einmal für Offenheit
und tolerant stand nun die größten
Oberlehrer kommen diese würden zur
Durchsetzung ihrer sogenannten Werte
mittlerweile auch Waffen sprechen lassen
wollen
Diplomatie jedenfalls gehört nicht zu
ihrer Stärke das beweisen sie gerade in
den Reihen der Ampelkoalition bei den
Bürgern arbeiten sich immer weniger
Respekt und Glaubwürdigkeit das sieht
man ja nicht nur in den
Umfrageergebnissen
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
bescheinigt zudem die Erfolge einer
eigenen Politik Tag für Tag wenn er von
Höchstpreisen für Energie einer
kommenden Rezession und den Niedergang
der deutschen Wirtschaft spricht und da
muss man sagen die Politik von Robert
Habeck wirkt sie sorgen nämlich dafür
aktiv dass wir zu einem Schwellenland
oder zum Sorgenkind Europas werden und
die sollten wirklich und das sollte ich
wirklich arabik sich mal überlegen
darüber nachdenken ob sie ihr Amt noch
zum Wohle des deutschen Volkes ausfüllen
oder sich besser wieder in die Welt der
Fabelwesen zurückziehen sollte
zum Bundeswirtschaftsminister
zum Bundesfinanzminister Herr Linder sie
sprachen in Dresden vor jung-handwerks
meistern und ich zitiere wo sie noch sie
erinnern sich Witze über ihren Kollegen
Lauterbach und Habeck machten vor
wenigen Wochen haben sie das dort den
jungen Handwerksmeister gesagt ich
zitiere wir müssen all das tun was
Energiepreise runterbringt und all das
unterlassen was Energiepreise steigen
lässt in einer solchen Situation muss
man alle Kapazitäten die verfügbar sind
am Netz behalten
allerdings über Ostern hinaus und er in
Dresden erzählen sie das den Leuten was
sie dort hören wollen und hier in Berlin
machen sie genau das Gegenteil mit ihrer
Politik das ist die verlogene Politik
der FDP das ist die verlogene Politik
gegen Handwerk und gegen Mittelstand und
das haben die Wähler in Niedersachsen
bereits erkannt
und da kann ich Ihnen nur sagen lieber
Herr Linda lügen haben kurze Beine und
deshalb sollten sich wirklich warme
Unterwäsche besorgen dann ist es bei
Bodenfrost
das Grundverhältnis von Angebot und
Nachfrage ebenfalls haben sie noch nicht
erkannt und es ist immer noch vorhanden
und dabei ist gerade das Angebot auf dem
Energiemarkt weiterhin stabil nur sie
verändern Werte Bundesregierung durch
ihre aggressive Sanktionspolitik den
Zugriff auf den Markt und reduzieren das
Angebot sie entscheiden nämlich
plötzlich nicht mehr bei jedem Anbieter
zu kaufen
und möchten von denen die mit
Deutschland noch Geschäfte machen
Produkte kaufen die sie gar nicht mehr
im Angebot haben das ist die Realität
und so verknappen sie selbst das
Energieangebot das beste Beispiel sind
dafür sind die Verhandlungen mit
Saudi-Arabien oder auch Kanada mit einem
Lächeln Kern sie nach Hause zurück und
müssen anschließend immer wieder
feststellen dass die sogenannten
Lieferanten von lngas überhaupt kein
adäquates Angebot für uns haben und da
sehen sie es wieder was wir immer sagen
in der Politik geht es nämlich um
Interessen herr Scholz und nicht nur um
Freundschaften das ist die Realität
meine Damen und Herren auf der
Regierungsbank machen sie sich endlich
ehrlich und gestehen sich selbst ein
dass ihr Konzept der Energiewende nicht
trägt und die Energiewende ist
gescheitert und auch sie haben Arzt
sollten das endlich realisieren Ihr
stellvertretender Bundesvorsitzender aus
Sachsen hat es bereits getan und sie
sind mitverantwortlich sie sind
mitverantwortlich dass diese
Energiewende gescheitert ist denn sie
haben die Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet
das sollen wir nicht vergessen
und die schädigen nachhaltig auch die
CDU was Generationen vor uns mühevoll
errichtet haben und alles nur um ihre
ideologischen Leitlinien zu erfüllen
eine gesunde Umwelt ist die
Lebensgrundlage für alle Menschen und
zukünftigen Generationen darüber sind
wir uns ja hier in diesem Haus einig wie
wir dieses zielsozial und wirtschaftlich
verträglich erreichen wollen das ist
jedoch die Frage und deshalb brauchen
wir im Bereich der Energieversorgung
Optionen jedoch sind in Deutschland eine
Unmenge an Windrädern und
unkonventionelle Erdgasförderung ebenso
wenig eine Option wie die endlose
Förderung von Braunkohle ja auch die ist
endlich das wissen wir wir brauchen
einen gesunden Energiemix der bezahlbar
und vor allen Dingen grundlastfähig ist
und gerade in einem Industrieland wie
Deutschland kann man nicht regelbare
grundlastfähige Energie wie Kohle
Kernenergie und Gas durch volatile
Energie wie Wind und Sonne ersetzen
und wer der Grünen Fraktionen dazu
braucht man nicht mal einen Studien oder
Berufsabschluss das ist einfach gesunder
Menschenverstand
sie möchten mit allen unmöglichen
Mitteln das westliche Werte und
Wirtschaftssystem retten und sind dabei
die Kommandeure des eigenen Niedergangs
aber gerade wir in Europa müssen doch
Interessen geleitete Politik für unsere
Bürger machen der Kontinent Europa hat
einen festen Platz in einer multipolaren
Weltordnung dafür brauchen wir Frieden
Stabilität und vor allen Dingen
wirtschaftliche Souveränität sie und
ihre einseitige US-amerikanische
Ausrichtung sind die Totengräber der
deutschen Wirtschaften das sehen wir
jeden Tag
kommen Sie bitte zum Wohle des Volkes
zur Vernunft versuchen sie endlich ihre
ideologischen Interessen zurückzustellen
im Moment verpokern sie alles Kapital
zugunsten einseitiger transatlantischer
Bündnisse bzw neuer Abhängigkeiten
Deutschland jedenfalls nutzt ihre
Politik nichts sie spalten damit nicht
nur Europa sondern auch die
Weltgemeinschaft noch eben sicher
geglaubte Wirtschaftspartner werden sich
ab und suchen sich neue Kontakte wie zum
Beispiel Saudi-Arabien und seinem Plan
den brix-staaten beizutreten und deshalb
fordere ich Sie für die Glaubwürdigkeit
gegenüber unseren europäischen Partnern
auch bei diesen Gipfel auf erstens
sorgen Sie schnellstmöglich dafür dass
die drei stillgelegten und die drei
aktiv verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke über
den April 23 hinaus die
Energieversorgung sichern dafür braucht
dies jetzt auch neue Brennelemente
und im übrigen wäre das genau die Stunde
des Parlaments wir fordern eine offene
von den Fraktionen nicht beeinflusste
Abstimmung namentlich denn hier geht es
um Verantwortung jeder Abgeordnete soll
das in seinem Wahlkreis erklären auch
diejenigen die sich der Realität
verweigern das ist Demokratie und das
fordern wir
zweitens klären Sie die
sabotageanschläge auf die
nordstream-leitungen auf sorgen Sie
dafür dass die kritischen Infrastruktur
auch geschützt wird und geschützt ist
dass durch die Pipelines auch wieder Gas
nach Deutschland und Europa geliefert
wird und drittens beenden Sie Ihre
wertegeleitete Sanktionspolitik und
stoppen Sie die Waffenlieferung an die
Ukraine helfen sie den Krieg in Europa
durch Verhandlungen zu beenden und hören
Sie auf Moral und Sittenpolizei hören
sie auf Moral und Sittenpolizei auf der
ganzen Welt zu spielen Herr Lamsdorf
agieren sie endlich souverän zum Wohle
unseres Landes und zum Wohle unserer
deutschen Bürger
vielen Dank
Tino kupala der Parteien Fraktionschef
der AF